[Musique]
bonjour l'écologie c'est la vie et la
vie c'est la diversité la diversité des
espèces
la diversité des cultures la diversité
des peuples
eh bien la france est une mosaïque de
communautés
elle est à l'image de cette table c'est
à dire c'est une diversité de langues
une diversité de tradition une diversité
de paysages une diversité de productions
locales
et c'est cette diversité là qui fonde
notre identité de corse de basques
d'alsaciens de breton degania de
bourguignons de flamands et de bien
d'autres
mais cette diversité là aujourd'hui elle
est menacée
est ce que demain la france ressemblera
à cette table là c'est à dire ayant
perdu tout ce qui fait précisément sa
richesse culturelle est ce que demain
notre pays aura perdu son âme
est ce que nous construisons aujourd'hui
une france anonyme
c'est la question il faut choisir oui en
train de werchter c'est très très bien
ces démonstrations sur les fromages mais
moi quand j'avais 20 ans bon j'étais
je gagnais pas encore très très bien ma
vie et puis c'est vrai que mon premier
réflexe j'ai mangé pendant deux ans des
hamburgers au truc du coin parce que
c'était rapide et j'ai l'impression ne
prendra pas ce qui était faux d'ailleurs
puisque sa mamie les intestins à genoux
à 20 ans je crois qu'on a du mal à
comprendre biens sociaux est né en
province dans une région précise de
comprendre un petit peu ce risque
d'appauvrissement qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire contre ça je crois
d'abord qu'il faut reconnaître
l'existence de ces identités de ces
diversités
il faut par exemple attribuer un statut
à ces langues et à ses cultures
régionales
cela veut dire aussi que l'on doit
intégrer dans le financement public les
écoles qui enseignent en bilingue
c'est à dire qu'ils enseignent aussi en
breton en basque encore soit l'exacte ya
par exemple
et puis il faut réaliser une véritable
régionalisation
car en 1993 la france sera le dernier
pays où les décisions importantes sont
prises à paris alors qu'en face de nous
l'allemagne l'italie l'espagne la
belgique ont des régions relativement
autonomes et bien nos régions à nous
n'ont aucun pouvoir réglementaire est-ce
que ça passe pas par un désir je veux
dire par là que mes petites nièces qui
sont du sud de la france il faudrait
qu'elle ait le désir d'apprendre par
exemple provençal je ne sais pas comment
motiver le désir ça doit jouer au niveau
de l'éducation je sais pas comment
celles vécues par des agriculteurs ou
des gens qui n'en terroir davantage oui
je crois que non je crois que nous avons
tous et toutes
encore des racines même lorsque l'on vit
à paris l'on a dans sa mémoire
cet enracinement mais il est sûr aussi
que pour que ces identités régionales
subsistent
il faut aussi qu'une économie rurale
subsistent car il faut bien prendre
conscience que nous sommes aujourd'hui
en face d'une transformation qui n'a pas
eu son pareil depuis le début du
moyen-âge faut savoir que demain si nous
continuons comme cela il y aura deux
fois moins d'agriculteurs et cela veut
dire que la tiers du territoire national
aura perdu sa population permanente
alors si la population disparaît dans
une région
et bien c'est le support même de cette
diversité qui disparaît si vous les
vivez comme ça
et d'agriculteurs dites moi je fais des
moutons je fais du blé chez des agneaux
ce que je paye ici ça c'est certain vite
dans le bourbonnais et je pense que si
on veut qu'ils aient neri culture qui
subsiste en france effectivement et
c'est important pas seulement pour
l'identité régionale mais pour la france
entière pour que tous nos territoires
sont occupés
il faut qu'on ait une agriculture qui
soit peut-être un petit peu moins
productive parce qu'on produit
maintenant largement à ces niveaux
d'europe mais peut-être un peu à l'image
de ce que je faisais à faire des
produits de qualité et donner aux
consommateurs des produits de bien
meilleure qualité
je crois que ça fera plaisir aux
agriculteurs de produire de la bonne
nourriture et ça fera plaisir aussi aux
consommateurs de mieux manger peut-être
et je crois que l'image qu'on avait des
fromages tout à l'heure c'est une bonne
image parce que c'est c'est riche et
varié et c'est certainement de la
nourriture qui plaît à produire aux
agriculteurs et qui plaît à manger pour
les consommateurs je crois qu'il faut
bien comprendre que nous avons
aujourd'hui une politique agricole qui
est complètement absurde
d'une part on a des excédents qui font
disparaître des agriculteurs nous allons
dépenser des sommes considérables pour
gelée de bonnes terres céréalières et
dans le même temps nous allons aussi
dépensé des centaines de millions pour
canaliser la loi faire disparaître des
zones inondables drainer le marais
poitevin pour produire davantage de maïs
c'est à dire à croître encore nos
excédents cette politique agricole ne
peut trouver d'issue que en développant
une production de qualité mais aussi en
admettant que l'agriculture aujourd'hui
et bien ne peut pas s'engager sur les
dans l'économie de la même manière
qu'une entreprise industrielle par
exemple nous proposons de supprimer les
quotas et de les remplacer par un
contrat de production pour chaque
agriculteur sur un contrat pour un
volume à produire sur lesquels il y a
une garantie de prix de telle sorte à
assurer à chaque agriculteur un revenu
suffisant
un peu comme ce qui existe aujourd'hui
en suisse et en autriche
je vais revenir sur les diversités là
un petit peu en arrière par exemple
comment vous arranger avec les kanaks
or nouvelle calédonie je crois que les
kanak sont aujourd'hui aux français ce
que les indiens d'amérique du nord était
hier aux colons anglais
nous sommes en face d'une civilisation
qui est différente de la nôtre
or les écologie sont solidaires de tous
les peuples en danger
aucune culture n'a le droit de faire
disparaître ou de soumettre une autre
culture
je crois que c'est ça le problème alors
ya nicolas ya une question terriblement
politicienne les jeunes et l'écologie
toi tu vis sa commande à mon avis
l'écologie ça intéresse surtout les
jeunes massage ils vont rester toujours
dans ben oui c'est le monde de l'an 2000
que quand je pars comment le pré pub
c'est aussi notre problème mon avis est
à l'impression que les eaux ne pose pas
les bonnes questions concernant
l'écologie
ce qui nous préoccupe moi vivons c'est
évidemment le chômage que j'ai j'ai pas
mal de copains qui sont au chômage et on
est on est en quelque sorte coincé entre
entre l'anpe et souvent un bois un
boulot sans intérêt
et puis bon des trucs comme comme le
nucléaire
on a vu et puis aussi comme leurs
mouvements on a vu ce que ça peut donner
rosie ça a été un choc l'écologie boom
comme ça un virus qui arrive un jour
donc c'est venu lentement et après que
j'ai eu mon fils et je me suis aperçu
des conditions de vie des conditions de
nos vies et surtout la peur du nucléaire
c'est une angoisse sourde mais kate qui
date quand même des années 50 70 c'est
un aperçu et a lentement et puis je
parle ou non prendre conscience petit à
petit et puis ça nous entraîne un état
de prendre conscience des tas d'autres
choses aussi dans la ville qui vit à la
ville ou à la campagne
jéhovah pari fou il faut pas pousser le
berceau trop près des poux légèrement
comme voilà contiennent tous étaient les
plus basses et la pollution qui viennent
de droite moi y'a un truc qui m'a choqué
c'est au moment de tchernobyl
j'ai téléphoné à une amie qui habitait
en allemagne qui a dit toujours en
allemagne qui a un petit enfant de l'âge
du lieu du mien alors j'y lis ça va elle
me dit non
les enfants sortent pas aujourd'hui
parce qu'il pleut j'ai un bon pourquoi
pas parce que l'on a interdiction de
faire sortir les enfants parce que le
nuage de tchernobyl est en train de
passer donc les enfants restent enfermés
à la maison et tout d'un coup ça m'a
choqué terriblement l'acte le plus
simple d'un enfant qui lie j'ai joué
dans le jardin non tu n'as pas le droit
à aujourd'hui c'est radioactifs et ça
c'était une heure et demie d'avion de
chez nous et chez nous peut-être on
aurait dû le faire aussi mais je tiens
surtout insisté sur sur ce problème
d'armement nucléaire
la france doit s'engager dans cette
délocalisation elle doit se débarrasser
de l'armé nucléaire
en participant aux négociations et le
premier acte de bonne volonté serait
d'arrêter immédiatement les essais
nucléaires à mururoa et puis nous
proposons aussi dans ce domaine de
sortir de la préhistoire d'innover par
exemple d'essayer d'expérimenter une
défense civile non violente c'est à dire
qui mobilise les femmes et les hommes
dans leur quartier leur commune pour
essayer de de réaliser une dissuasion
économique stratégique vis-à-vis d'une
agression éventuel ça c'est un tout un
programme c'est de changer totalement la
mentalité
de sortir l'armée tiré c'est presque
candien dirais-je
mais je crois qu'il faut il faut que
notre société évolue dans ce domaine
c'est un changement de mentalité c'est
vrai c'est une révolution culturelle
il est évident que si demain nous
voulons que la france soit comme le
disent les eaux de la troisième
puissance économique et militaire bien
cela veut dire en effet que nous allons
accumuler encore davantage d'armes pour
faire sauter la planète que nous allons
encore dépenser davantage d'argent dans
ce domaine mais cela veut dire aussi que
nous allons entrer sur le terrain de la
compétition internationale avec tous les
dégâts que cela comporte
ils y trouveront d'ailleurs si je peux
me permettre de voir que des gens comme
harold ping terre en angleterre est un
militant écologiste forcené j'étais très
surpris des dernières interviews de
marguerite yourcenar qui étaient des
interviews tout à fait écologistes juste
avant qu'elle disparaisse
et quand même que elie wiesel la
conclusion qu'il a eu à 7 sur 7 était
une conclusion terriblement écologistes
puisqu'il est le seul vrai danger
aujourd'hui le seul vrai beau grand
problème qui me fait peur c'est le
nucléaire alors j'ai l'impression un
petit peu que notre génération je sais
pas si nicolas de vie comme ça mais
quand on s'est rendu compte qu'elle
tchernobyl un réacteur sur trois
réacteurs d'une centrale a pu mettre en
danger la moitié de l'europe
c'est vrai que ça nous fait quand même
terriblement frissonner quoi et que nick
a certainement des énergies nouvelles a
cherché nous allons interrompre un
moment par une note d'humour par une
note de poésie avec marc jolivet que
nous retrouverons dès hier à chacun de
nos rendez vous comme un feuilleton
je suis vert en vraiment je suis vert
non pas vers bouteilles non verts tout
simplement comme les arbres l'herbe les
martiens attention je suis pas né vers
j'imagine la tête de ma pauvre mère
bonjour madame votre petit bébé il est
ouvert aux femmes
landreau je suis né comme tout le monde
comme vous et moi
surtout moi d'ailleurs non c c'est après
que je suis devenu vert remarquez quand
j'étais jeune
je suis passé par d'autres couleurs
quand j'étais étudiant le rouge le noir
le bleu quand j'étais dans l'équipe de
france vous le saviez scène j'étais dans
l'équipe de france
abbassi j'ai même failli être jaune au
moment d'une grève mais non non ça
c'était pas mon truc
non ça s'est fait lentement tout
doucement à force de me promener peut
respirer d'écouter de regarder les
autres tu es mais je suis devenu vert ça
s'est fait tout doucement
c'est beaucoup plus long pour les autres
couleurs parce que ça vienne l'intérieur
et que ça s'adressant vois quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec les modes
parce que si on est vert parce qu'on
veut bien y a pas davantage adverse mais
je sais je le suis ça se vend pas bien
le verbe ça rapporte rien ça veut pas le
pouvoir
ça veut pas les richesses
on veut tout simplement que tous soient
un peu plus vert non non en fait on veut
que tout reste un peu plus vert pourquoi
parce que ça fait des millions d'années
que c'est comme ça et qui doit y avoir
une raison
et si on veut pas que nos enfants
naissent vert mais vraiment vert vert
qui soit avec des taches rouges et
jaunes
bah c'est maintenant que se joue c'est
pour ça que je suis vert non ne touchez
pas votre poste de télévision non ne
jouez pas avec la couleur non on ne
touche pas à son poste de télé c'est
pénible les gens qui touchent
qu'est ce que je disais oui même quand
vous aurez tout état que chacun ira
fêter la victoire
ou pleurer sur la défaite je serai
encore vert et j'espère que la terre
elle aussi elle sera encore longtemps
verte vers pommes vertes brunes vers
poireau vers ruisseau père comme
l'espoir
bon allez broyer pas du noir le vert
faudra bien les passer c'est normal
c'est par là qu'on a commencé
si c'est pas par là qu'on a commencé un
nom
7 c'est par là qu'on a commencé oui ça a
commencé par le vert mais ça va
continuer comme en toutes les couleurs
politiques se sont succédé au pouvoir
depuis dix ans est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que quelque chose a changé
aujourd'hui ils nous proposent les mêmes
remèdes
mais ce sont ces remèdes qui ont fait la
démonstration que malgré cela le chômage
a augmenté et ce sont ces remèdes qui
nous valent aujourd'hui la pollution la
dégradation de notre environnement et
l'accumulation de risques considérables
alors demain si vous voulez que sa
chance il faut que le message soit clair
c'est à dire qu'au premier tour
eh bien le vote vers leur dise
clairement que vous voulez une société
conviviale une société qui soit capable
de respecter nos diversités nos
identités
[Musique]